5 25 on your wednesday morning well it's
not beethoven it's not mozart but clark
county may have just composed a tune
that you could call
variations on a speed bump we all know
speed bumps right did you catch this on
the news the other day we got county
commissioner tick sega bloom talking
about the speed bump they have
introduced called the speed cushion on
spencer in the near southeast valley
the reality is we need to stop
in these older neighborhoods
particularly people cutting through
in this case between flamingo and desert
inn so we're trying to figure out a way
to slow traffic down we now have these
new speed cushions which are not cement
they're they're rubber they even sent us
video
of the speed cushion
in action
hang on
[Music]
yeah
okay
try to calm yourself
that was your speed cushion now clark
county says this is a pilot project to
see what the actual impacts are to
traffic and the neighborhood call it
whatever you want if it gets folks to
slow down i'm all for it buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone if
there is something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8
com